everybody was going on play you're
welcome to Monday Bailey yeah you guys
to class we are very excited here we're
done in San Diego for comic-con which
hasn't started yet but our special guest
today is from the Padres wilmyer what's
going on and your brother Bo that's
right but let's see these socks real
quick up here there we go look these
socks let's see can I take this out oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah that's red that can
feel to see the other one boom that's
right love it brotherly Wella brotherly
love we're gonna play love Mario Kart 8
and we're here we've got Elise sweets
posters here Bo just got into superhero
movies exactly and we got review loved
it alright The Hulk is the man dude he
was my favorite guy growing up yeah cuz
he just gets stronger and stronger
awesome and then we grew up in two homes
basically we're giant giant huge me
that's right so let's play some Mario
Kart man let's play I just introduced
these guys to the Wii U so they've never
played the Wii U before what's the game
you play well
Tiger Woods oh nine oh nine that's the
only game I love it
alright so pick your guy you're gonna go
around oh and if you can't pick him that
hit B did you already pick your guy
there yeah
alright so I'm the yellow thing I think
yeah I think you're you but I'm Donkey
Kong right up here Mario no I'm down
there you pick yours you're your baby
you're yeah good you're picking right
now no not enough oh yeah there it's you
okay area per this oh here we go all
right now you gotta like I don't I don't
customize mine I just go the clue is e
this is all stuff for your car it
doesn't matter doesn't matter yeah yeah
it's gonna be it's gonna be skill rather
than in stuff you're hit I hit
perfect all right don't care we don't
care about this look a little slow cuz
you guys are new to know you want to go
fast yeah all right I like event I like
it three races
all right now here we go what what does
this mean this is these are the tracks
around okay for somebody's never seen
Mario car before this must be incredibly
yeah insane Nintendo 64 okay okay
different played old-school you played
old-school
I love it all right what do you think
let's go see give me where's the hardest
one the hardest one dude all right I
mean these are the new I never even seen
these tracks what was for good let's do
it in there let's do yeah exactly
exactly here we go like so a go a is gas
okay the left stick obviously J and you
can if you're feeling if you're feeling
spicy the right trigger lied so yeah
jump slide oh it's okay so like a drift
yeah like a drifter yeah I liked it and
then the left trigger is your your item
so jump turn and it slides are exactly
right what's the deal one that we go one
two three go like I like to I like to
gut it I just do like ay ay ay ay ay ay
just go for it yeah I remember that was
something say hey far that's good I get
to see you hey escrito portugal I love
it we got a little bit some Portugal
fans in the house today oh dude my guys
must straighten the wall huh wait what
oh oh no wait is that cuz you're pushing
oh no yes switch the switch you take
this guy I'll put the handicap I'll play
my baby okay
I'm not afraid I'm not afraid oh crap
your donkey yeah you're gonna hate
Donkey Kong other way let's fly my upper
left upper love yeah oh yeah oh this guy
is all about the right oh my god oh man
good what did you do to this boat oh man
there's a madman
oh my god well I don't think I'm gonna
be winning this race saboteur this is
your plane hola holaa baby this is for
you Anna
oh man well I'm a deep 12 by the way I
went too deep 12
oh my god so Bo
you you got you what's your sock
situation is this it's just an anomaly
or is this a new I'm in the socks man
you know have you got any of these socks
it's a new thing you're just getting
into socks yeah what did you do it in
this controller this is a hole not going
backwards this is some mess you guys are
lucky this time you guys are right here
do you have a collection of socks no no
actually when I found them there we go
you don't need to explain that people
know that oh just the open window that's
the open window woody me Oh cuz we're
blocking the bottom-left oh all right
that's right hey mixer 401 what's
happening oh my god yeah I'm just
running into the wall maybe I should
just give up on this well so you got you
got a bone spur removed your bone spur
let's see this let's see the scar dude
oh man I was telling are you trying to
win about I was hoping that could
distract you enough that's awesome and
so and what do you think I'm gonna be
back so I start hitting rap it also
breaks I'm pretty except again all right
that's awesome
and dude I'm just gonna have to take a
knee on this one I'm just driving up
your thing it's awful dude this kook
this track is this hard this is
ridiculous oh hey teacher you sir thank
you for coming good to see you chrono 85
hello hello humans this is a new world
for you this is an opposite of what you
do for a job I've never seen this room
yeah for a job you're outside I did the
Paris gripping one time periscoping well
I haven't done Paris gonna be a nunnery
oh yeah yeah the line thing when it's a
periscope huh what did you periscope Oh
studio in LA and like the first after
the first game of the year
uh-huh it was kind of weird does it
freak you does the live stuff freak you
out or not really now the life stuff
them free man is just weird that I was
looking people are looking at me and I
couldn't see them right right that is
kind of alright I'm never gonna finish
this did you guys both finish all right
there's no way I'm gonna be able to I
gotta reset this controller this is
awful yeah see you wanted the hardest
course man that's why I wanted were
before dangerous dangerous that's the
most popular gaming product or people
play the most oh I don't know I mean
quality
yeah Call of Duty is pretty awesome
that's a that's a pretty full sure
what's your favorite roller say my
favorite game
oh that's Tom your favorite color my
favorite color yeah I like a new one
with the power suits advanced warfare
from why a man dude it's awesome you
have to do a reset
these controllers are killing me
though I'll never consider wearing any
back go through it again it's like why
it's my thing you like the tactile oh
yeah oh I got big hands and I got you
know calluses on them but I just have a
better feel hitting people know me about
not using batting notes I can't not use
them really are you are you worried your
hands gonna torn up but you like it well
mainly that they're kind of torn up a
little bit that's off but it looks cool
it looks cool how many cheeks somewhat
and you'll have that yeah you know mate
it's like it's like it carved out of
wood yeah yeah that's awesome
do you more eyes no never moisturize
moisturize it gets slick you need to
have your growing sandpaper on your
hands they're growing sandpaper I love
it oh my god this is awful
this is the worst thing that's ever
happened in the history of the world
Beth we got some more questions no we
can't and we won't get off her back tom
video games doesn't hurt my wrist while
playing yeah perfect
shut it down shut it down not to start
it back up sorry my controller was dying
and I don't want to lose every single
time so I had to shut it down no that
will fire it back up oh my god what's
happening here this is great so sweet so
you're from you guys are from North
Carolina Tom Waits
so I mean you're on the road so much
that I guys do have a place here no I
have a condo you have a condom yeah is
it weird like so you I got drafted by
the word up Royals right and then you
got traded to Tampa Bay and so three
fields yeah if that's awesome right it's
pretty cool is it weird when you get
traded to to have to like root against a
team that you were on you don't ever
want to read like last year when Kent I
said he was in the World Series I was
pulling for those oh yeah yeah yeah for
sure I mean that's the thing I guess
it's like it's all friendly between you
guys yeah
yeah it's a business it's a business
exactly and now that being said is there
a team that you would need to be traded
to no it's a vaguely yeah that's awesome
I mean what if you didn't play baseball
what what do you think you'd be doing
besides hangin book be a baseball coach
yeah I mean what else do you like to do
besides play baseball and Tiger Woods oh
nine maybe you'd be a cobbler I play
golf a lot you play golf I'm not great
I'm good I'm okay you're not great yeah
I wish I was better like what's your
handicap I don't know anything about
golf it's actually like ninety is that
good it's okay all right I mean I'm not
a Tiger Woods yeah that's true thank
goodness yeah yeah that's it means a lot
of things
exactly I wonder what's happening no we
need to do yeah did you hit the console
thing golf ball but I've seen people
like take people's clothes and put it in
a bucket of water and put it in the
freezer Jesus have you ever have you
ever pranked anyway or been prints no
because I don't want it coming back to
me I don't that I love it I love it
that's true man this guy you know guys
in the big leagues have a ton of money
so they can do yeah Karma's a [ __ ] yeah
literally plant like a bunch of animals
and you come in someone's car I've heard
about some ideas first in somebody's car
crickets like a bag full of crickets
that's brilliant Wow yeah that's pretty
wild
that is brilliant all right here we go
I'm Luigi no I'm my blue is that me is
that me I think that's me
I think that's why the controller's
missing oh yeah controllers messed up
no no hey go grab a controller out of
that and that been any other room would
you and so we got a bunch of controllers
alright let's just play again man
handy oh it's right here give me this
with that Beth come back Beth come back
all right let's get out of here yeah
yeah I gotta hook my new controller up
now you guys are big big troubles all
right here we go
all right now at vs Jesus God verdicts
permits
okay now I'm down to the left all right
I'm baby Mario I got the pipe frame now
you guys are going down
finally benef controller squash your ass
question for will what pitcher in the
major major leagues do you hate facing I
don't hate facing but he's I don't see
him very well
I enjoy facing but he gets me a lot of
his grades go let's go Russian who does
that Greinke he's good
why what what about him is he too
handsome you get distracted by his
beautiful eyes yeah yeah no but he's
really good he gives me a tough time at
the plate I love it and how do you um do
you are there superstitions you have or
anything like that besides not using the
gloves
um so I'm not crazy superstitious but I
will definitely put my glove or bat or
helmet back in the same spot if I get a
hit
and I'll make I'll change me if I know
yeah what did that start
once I got into pro ball like Ronson
I started doing it really yeah I noticed
it work good yeah all right so I'm lower
left will were you at top right easier
track look yeah this is the easiest
track so you get problems here we're
gonna have some problems we're gonna
have some problems
all right I'm gonna get up there oh my
god this control I can't even tell you
it's so great to be able to turn right
come on great
so he said Greinke's greasy greasy this
greasy mean good yeah maybe maybe that's
a new thing the kids are saying
hashtag greasy but you're not one of
these guys who doesn't wash your socks
for life oh come on what do we do
Bowie's though but boys watch those
socks and like seriously but watch them
since you gotta write we just win
yesterday so first time he's worn up
since that I love it free now what do
you got are you guys beep North Carolina
you guys big fireworks guys no blow
stuff up down there what's going on down
there North Carolina
fruit Furtick what does that mean no so
then I go a French a man yes
like what with lazy boys you got your
lazy ever heard of Thomasville Furniture
no I'm not a big furniture guy I don't
know wow I didn't know I was hanging on
a couple furniture snobs what do you
guys you guys let me guess you guys
probably have accent chairs right you
know I don't even know what that is but
somebody on the staff so Noah's saying
she got a new accent chair I think it's
just a chair you don't sit in you put
your clothes on it's just for look I
think it's just for looks it's an
uncomfortable chair how hot is this
couch rate the furniture boys the
furniture twins dang do maybe I should
open a side business oh my god yeah
we're here at a professional athlete so
you've got another professional yeah
you've got the you got great reflexes
yeah you hit 100-mile fast balls crazy
well solid it's a pretty solid maybe you
guys should open a furniture business do
you think about that you know get the
furniture design it's in your blood
it's my furniture see I love it hey
Chris Albert what's up what's going on
yeah else is the guy in the middle
that's bow using Jarrow controls no he's
not do you want to use general controls
where you go like this that's Larry's
yeah we're starting dude okay come on
not for long
which a boat you just got to come on
super here movies do you think you're
gonna go start reading comic books and
all that I don't know about readin
there's not a lot of reading in comic
books there's a lot of pictures we'll
what's one thing that would surprise
your fans to know about you besides the
fact that you're really into furniture
and you're gonna open your own further
business specializing in accent chair
you know my two hobbies are ping pong
and golf ping pong damn dude give up
watch you ping pong videos on YouTube I
got I mean I went I went to this ping
pong tournament here in San Diego really
and I thought we go there meet everybody
yeah oh you're a plate I wouldn't play
oh damn and anyway so I went played and
I got read really these guys were
unbelievable it's
Almighty God dude what what first place
this is ridiculous I need to control her
that's only going left I was doing
better when I couldn't turn right
Gillies oh my god
this is awesome I used to go when I was
in New York I used to go to this law for
these guys who play ping pong they would
have people over and this dude Wally
used to be on the Olympic team alright
maybe try off the Olympic team or
something
best guy they're like this tiny little
black dude and he would he was so good
he had this little paddle mate it was
like this big and he played with people
yeah and then and he would kill him
people oh you're still play on the
paddle it so he would use his phone and
this is like flip phone days you'd play
with a flip phone he's crazy
now I did see when I went there there
were paddles people are practical and
pollicis but yeah that's crazy right
that's awesome those guys would've beat
me with that thing it's insane like
they're so good Tommy sure they called
me a garage player what does that mean
like Jesus it's like a like a casual
yeah I guess they like it's like an
insulted so they got me that's hilarious
no but it was fun man let me know where
I really wasn't people yeah I guess it
kind of put you in your place yeah did
you okay cool come on in here you want
to tell us doing a take over here are
you doing Wow just jump in for a second
I'm terrible yeah you play you play here
you're gonna be baby Mario you're in
last you're in the bottom what do I do
so you have to catch me hey yeah alright
just go today anybody there we go so
just hit hold it hold it you want this
one you want this phone yeah when you
then you turn around here I go [ __ ]
there we go
[Applause]
I hate them what why is he always
underwater yeah you died you died why
did my guy died both because here to
grab you if you just keep running often
you need to go over the pipes so they'll
fight over the pipes over the place
right will is killing it though he's
also professional as a professional
athlete yes I'm not a professional video
game
hand-eye coordination you are one of the
greatest human beings on the plan 2013
Rookie of the Year yeah I know
so what I'm saying is it's not fair I am
not known for any ability will is
getting into ping-pong no I don't but
let me guess you're really good I
thought it was good but there was a
ping-pong tournament here in San Diego
but I thought I went and played and I
thought I was gonna kill everyone
yeah I didn't win a game you didn't win
one game about one game yeah humbling
you know what's amazing is to see an NBA
player play in a softball game they're
terrible
there he's got like six foot eight guys
and they're the best at what they do and
they get paid a fortune and then you see
them on a softball field they got
nothing they're the worst guy in the
company so you should thank your lucky
stars every day that you don't to wear
the Padres uniform from the 70s you know
on do you remember that we were the
throwback sometimes yeah but it's crazy
it's the craziest the only thing worse
was the Astros uniform from the 70s
remember that yeah yeah they're dressed
like the Riddler on Batman I kind of
like the throw bags
I like the Padres hat from the 70s as
you've seen our calendar what's that
our camo Sunday Jersey camo don't can
see you on the field man
a bunch of heads and gloves together you
can steal a base and you can you know
you can you can you can start to steal a
base and then you can stop halfway
through and just die I have no idea
where you are I haven't a way to improve
the game of baseball if you're
interested you know I want to pitch it
to you since you're such a great
baseball player
I think they should change the rules or
the time I was speeding it up a little
bit I think they should change the rules
so that after you hit the ball at the
plate you can choose to run to third
order first but once you choose the
direction you have to commit to that
direction and take right then you're
committed to that direction then you've
got think of how that changes the whole
game
the strategy right and when two players
pass each other one headed to first and
one headed to second one of them has to
burst into flame these are these are
ideas that I have to make the game even
more fascinating some reason they think
I'm an idiot
I know okay so how'd you get cognitive
there we asked them in a we asked in
them well yes maybe brought Bo but Luke
check out both socks but you think those
are exactly today and they're great or
you look very 360 or three days earlier
this is your brother nice to you you
didn't say there was a lot of conviction
they rule your high spot picked oh yeah
there we go just hit a hit a bunch of oh
god all right I just keep hitting it
keep it here oh yeah there we go
sorry go got it good I think you're
gonna be bottom left don't go down and
hit there we go thank you did you play
this a lot hang out his first time
do you play video games at all no I play
them the only time I play them is when
I'm on camera
I always suck in silence it had a chrono
85 chrono
five there we go chrono eighty-five I
acknowledge you know Jordan slansky
is not going to join us okay Lola
because he's a freak let's give a shout
out to elke lk b d in france even vive
la France
exactly shady fresh I'm glad you like my
shirt
have you ever played international ball
will your played almost sees anyone oh
no do you guys what I've played
international Mario made in Japan and
there I'm a god you play sports in high
school you know it's funny you bring it
up yo
I played women's volleyball and you know
what it was fantastic
I was terrible but I was just I was a
total perv I was trying to talk to them
I was you know I didn't make it on my
attic ability let's put it that way
we're not sure how I made it yeah you
know it comes and goes
it's like a super power of it departs me
sometimes all right I love the show well
thank you that's very nice of you
oh my god are we jumping over crackers
now yeah I don't know where we are
who's in the top right top rabies where
am i I'm down that's Conan that's why
wait what am i doing in play I'm doing
really well
oh my god it wasn't even well that's
your fault you can't be doing really
well if you're not even paying attention
I'm so freaked out to talk to him star
athlete even you're even keeping your
eye on me Conan's in the Dodge okay this
is too much very much candy mountain
this is terrible
well what's your workout regimen alright
what do you think of these questions
because I want to work out maybe this we
can pick up some tips on hey you know
today's the first day I can actually do
strengthening whoa really there we go
they say today awesome way to start slow
yeah what's up my so I had surgery on my
wrist my left breast and I haven't been
able to do any strengthening to it till
today show the scar it's a serious scar
he doesn't want to take his hand off the
thing I see this super competitive
so you had the surgery surgery now was
it cosmetic for your wrist did I
understand you is like just to look good
isn't it true that's the rumor is that
you just wanted a better looking wrist
silicone is even danger your career for
cosmetic wrist surgery
which by the way I've had yeah it took a
year off my I look people see my resume
think I'm in my league
is it too late for me to be a
professional you know what I saw Will
Ferrell do it yeah I play center field
he played right field yeah really that's
not like you could do it he I'll tell
you about will will can get in great
shape but then he lets himself go he's
like he's got a good arm
no he's got a good arm but when he lets
himself go he eats like seven sheet
cakes that you get her supermarket balls
and drinks just a ton of Gatorade and he
mixes sugar into it free but I was in
the gym this morning yeah yeah I did
cardio I mean you guys can tell just by
looking
I'm a gym rat you bring him here to
laugh at me are you guys competitive
when you play stuff that's not yes yeah
always can put oh what's the eggs like
put put two days ago against each other
we were trying to kill each other
really oh my god is it just you or any
other what's your do you like baseball
as well yeah he's going to apply to the
state make sure okay alright that's
great you have you're gonna soon be
stronger faster than yours
alright I gotta go I gotta get run to
all right guys okay I'll see you
Thursday but listen I open I will fight
both of you at the same time any day
this week in the parking lot we strip to
the waist and we just go after when I'm
cornered on a monster you'll be really
shocked
you better not be wearing some goofy
slippers when you come fight me
alright say goodbye to the chat say
goodbye to the bad chat later see you
later chat awesome cool Thank You Renee
very cool to meet you and then there was
one that's really well this is gonna be
a bit of a letdown but let's continue
playing shall we yeah pump it back
big thanks to wil Myers the Padres for
coming by follow him on twitter at will
Myers that's Wilm ye AR s and on
instagram that will underscore myers and
of course i follow at padres on twitter
pod San Diego Padres mlb.com that's a
real URL so make sure follow those guys
and cool thanks a lot see you guys later
awesome
all right and now being back that's
right exactly you guys have been waiting
a shirt edg's heck I love it
see some yeah leg largos fever the
screams feet all right you know let's
get out of here we're gonna we're gonna
play some serious how do I wait let's
get out of this I know
all right so take your guy I'm gonna be
the laughs to you to me right and then
it was just prior that's right breath it
brings into viewers introduce it we got
Jason Amell a creeper in the corner over
here
hey Angie Angie a sec all right here we
go
I'm gonna be okay I download these new
packs I'm gonna be somebody new I'm
going I'm going to link Aroo here
whoo I just like the name wild wiggler
that's what they call me on the streets
they called me on the streets the wild
wiggler don't know why I can't get into
it the court the court said I'm not
allowed to say why the courts have said
I also have to stay 300 yards away for
every penny school or Taco Bell that's a
different situation
Wolfe apostle came for Conan states are
bad yeah I love it
you on the street every day would start
exactly its features of girl do you
think you can handle 200 cc's that's how
fast it is and how much I sure how much
sugar I do
oh my god ok let's not let's do to be
fun all right here we go the buttons are
a is is gas the right trigger is like
drift now you'll be going to a corner
slide left trigger it's like your
audience is use your and then this left
stick is Turner
yep I love it I love it hashtag game all
right let's do it let's just start I
mean we already did that one will do
let's do something easy to set me easy
let's do something easy Mario circuit
all right sunshine Airport
you're like an airport you like an air
boy nobody likes airports weird it's a
transient environment that's the
transient so listen learn what do you
guys think by the way of our sweet
danger dead Ruth R while helps us out
Jeff and Paolo helps us out with this
you got your minecraft no we're not high
that's that's lunch time we do all the
drugs can Carol one I don't I don't want
to say something in German
cuz a that I don't know what it is cuz
they I don't trust Germans I'm half
German North part German and and B I'm
not sure what that means
Beth let be Aaron left stick is the best
oh whoops say I give you a little head
start there better you I'm on the wild
wiggler look at my little hat blowing in
the breeze Oh God
I think it's very unsafe breasts okay
please see for us to be just driving
around on a runway it's horrifying
oh yeah it's 200 CCS a pure Mario
karting action Oh this wild wiggler
[Music]
this week we are going to be not just
streaming today we're gonna be streaming
every single day from noon to 1:00
Pacific time right here on twitch TV /
team Coco or if you're watching us on
YouTube common code go and we're gonna
have special guest all week long and I
can't guarantee I'll be playing a wild
wiggler at all but it's going pretty
well so far
that's cool wilmyer stop by man being a
baseball player be like oh that's right
you love the Red Sox
they're just seething with anger that he
was here just slowly trying to like
poison him or something
how's the Red Sox our enemies are there
it's a Padres and Dodgers bloody crazy
gamer you get more viewers if you just
put the cam Jim than a Wonder Woman by
Wonder Woman I'm assuming you mean that
Morosky
have you seen the photos I think one a
Romans in Batman vs Superman played by
who
is badass
my Wonder Woman I mean the Wonder Woman
poster behind that thanks a lot to make
me defend bets honor I'll do it you can
turn around these
got do the wild wiggler seven alright
that's okay
that's alright we have invited Jordan to
play with us at almost every single week
Jordan refuses but maybe we're all by
the way here in San Diego when the
Spreckels theater here does in downtown
San Diego and our offices are in this
actually in this and we're all kind of
sharing one giant office so I'm hoping
my loud voice is carrying down the hall
towards Jordan is sitting around instead
of a high five
nope you do tingle as you come down left
cuz high fives are so aggressive but
instead you get the tingle to get in
there you can also do just little take
this that's right
that's a fit you're walking by you do
like they wore and it's also good if you
just across the room you're not close
enough just be like all right Rach all
right
for god sakes all right chat tell us
what we should play here are the choices
Bell cup Triforce cup egg cup or
crossing cup Jordan did not attack maybe
with these mental powers it's very
possible when court when codon records
the show yes I do watch any fridge hot
grill
someone said email I think you meant
girl but I'm gonna try for its Triforce
Triforce alright it's Eli Triforce
linked here we go it's probably hard put
your [ __ ] big-boy pants on death pull
your pants up it's time pull my pants up
it's time for the Triforce Cup here we
go
Triforce Triforce Triforce here we go
[Music]
I've been here I've been to this one
exactly I'm into this love it here we go
cat peach I'm gonna show you what meow
means hashtag me ouch uh wait I played
this one this is an old track Oh No
is this an old track this is like a
redone oh wow whoa this is awesome
oh you Hale there we go
what does the boomerang do exactly yeah
I know but it doesn't do much by the way
one of the greatest weapons ever Mad Max
the Razer boomerang with a kid
oh god this is kind of like half like
old mining town and then half Tron it's
like Indiana Jones and the Tron yeah oh
dude spiked shell blue shell is the best
thing ever think if you hit someone
else's mushroom it gives you a boost
wild wiggler dude is killing it right
now fourth place
oh very careful very careful very
careful oh Jesus it's cheer Bethan know
what's not your beth on yeah it will
only make you sad yeah exactly
it comes to being mediocre that's the
best there is Beth tell people about
your newsletter yeah guys Beth has a
newsletter what's it called what's it
called the best newsletter that's great
it's awesome what kind of things can you
find on the a letter it's that to go go
read it Renegades on this stream ma'am
guys you're just joining us hey you
missed wilmyer some Padres which is
great you also miss Connor O'Brien from
the show colored on TV yes and you can
find all the highlights on twitch.tv
switch off TV / team cocoa and on our
youtube channel and I got knocked off
twice which is great I hate everything
okay cool I think people just jealous
the wild weight my man they see this
wild wiggler coming down the road
they're like damn that thing was good I
can't tell popping I'm out O'Malley very
sick he's very sick I can't forget
though he's laughing or coughing there
are jokes is it a coffee disapproval
they were laughing my god well it's a
cop laughs it's a cab or cloth have some
player balls how about some player
scared cuff me ouch
all right that one's gonna be sick of
that but we are gonna be streaming
hashtag stream cocoa every single day
here from comic-con and San Diego Conant
on I should say from noon to 1:00
Pacific time right here and twitch.tv
slash Team Coco youtube.com slash Team
Coco and now we're gonna special guests
every single day you never know if conan
will stop by or not you'll never know if
I spill a Coke Zero on the floor and
I've Dannielynn it for 20 minutes
anything could happen and if you missed
the live action you can always see out
the entire full stream on our twitch
channel and on our youtube channel or
highlights as well if you just maybe you
only have a couple minutes maybe yeah
maybe you're starving you're going
through the drive-through Taco Bell you
need a Crunchwrap supreme and you just
want to watch something while they're
making your order fire up the highlights
I might have just that might have been
TMI
hungry and I might have just spoiler
alert told you gots what I want to eat
for lunch in about 15 minutes
but yeah the highlights are great too
[Music]
yeah for real start at fifty CC that
says 20 CC view of the option nuns on
drugs wow that's a quite a user name
nuns don't need drugs they have the Lord
all right Steven X it's pretty cool
right
Steven X live live streaming is amazing
that we can talk to you guys and you
could talk back well tight back oh god
oh my god this is great
nuns on drugs you're gonna you're loving
this low man
I gotta say man you're a if you're a
Raceway if you're like designing a
racecourse why would you put in
90-degree turns driving that's a
terrible idea it's very dangerous all
these tracks are very dangerous
[Music]
oh boy no wait does this mean we're
going to Valhalla fast guard you guys
should play some fighting games yeah
hopefully we'll play a little injustice
maybe tomorrow or the next day or
sometime this week that is certain
superhero related death is extremely fun
very violent person
shady fridge I agree the original
Rainbow Road on 64 was possibly the best
track mario has ever created and the one
with the least amount of right angles
I'm still not convinced this is a great
idea
I will say Nintendo knows how to make a
beautiful one game who's excited for the
Mario maker by the way that's where you
get to make your own levels in Mario it
was that guy No
who was that was any free this year this
wild wiggler is just getting taken to
town on the Rainbow Road man
it's a lot of alliteration come on man I
need it
God ah yeah exactly oh it's been the
design and it said they designed the
raceway with 90-degree angles in the
this is the size of a small horse by the
way if I told you about my desire
there's any geneticist watching please
make a tiny elephant please tiny little
teacup lol I'm pleading now to the
scientific community I really want
before I die to own a tiny little
elephant if I had the the science
knowledge I would do it myself
I'll experiment on humans I'll do
whatever it takes just please make a
tiny yellow bow how great would it be
like your eat dinner at little elephants
like me like you feed them like little
peanuts like this outfit like this size
little Thai elephant
let me great note elephants but a little
while ago they had they had those
commercials with a tiny giraffe and I
felt like maybe scientists were sitting
up and taking notice like oh wait it's
starting to get any popular culture cuz
that's like how things happen like for
instance nobody started caring about the
environment so it was cool you know what
I'm saying then like it was cool to have
a Prius
you know then everyone wanted a priest
now it's cool have a Tesla you know it's
gotta be soon it'll be baby elephants
and will you know will ruin the
ecosystem it'll be worth it telling you
tiny elephants guys a rear done no Kony
did not go to e3 this year we went but
he couldn't go because we were actually
getting ready for Comic Con for Conan
Con actually hashtag Conan time so we're
gonna be doing shows down here in San
Diego Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
and we're very very excited from the
Spreckels theater where we currently are
right now
and yeah if you're in San Diego come on
down and say hi or see us walking around
and say hi or just say hi to yourself
and imagine we're hearing it or come
onto the stream we're gonna be streaming
every day and write high on the keyboard
and then we'll see it we could say hi
back there's so many ways to say hi you
could tweet at us
you could Instagram comment us oh yeah
oh I actually did somebody the boomerang
me ouch thank you
the one wiggler is good on the turns and
terrible in the straightaway oh my god
dude holy crap I have everything look at
this this is awesome I got the lazy
susan of items it's amazing
got the buffet I don't super buff that
yep yep yep you holding that intent
what's going on back there
hello glitch SS p.m. good to see you
oh man please please please third come
on oh please come back
give me that mushroom give me that
mushroom
oh god you guys Mario Kratz like life
you know you're in first place then
you're in seventh place then you're even
back in it then you're moving back in
with your your mom Mary Blair back in
Michigan then we all move it was very
blurred then we go and work at work at
Best Buy just mapping out the rest of my
life very sad way
yeah Manuel 64 The Creeper really is a
creeper Jason O'Malley open creeper
that's the coffin creaking yeah oh I got
them everything thing again oh man
oh this is great
come on peach
damnit
wild wiggler great on the turns
Oh get there get there get there yes
all right before this' Abed deco etch
what's wrong forget Best Buy I'm 37 I
worked there part-time never has a
college degree there's nothing more
nothing around working at Best Buy I
used to read at Kmart it was awesome
here's I don't like about Best Buy
nothing about Best Buy it is the best
buy I'm from in Ann Arbor
smells weird it smells like pencils you
go in there I don't know why so it's
like somebody's making pencils in the
back I hate the smell of pencils it's
weird it's like it's a woodsy graphite e
weird smell that smells weird
so I said specifically going back home
move in with my mom which by the way
you're welcome to do I'll have to clear
it with her but the best place well is
weird man I don't like it I like going
in there it's not good it's not good
time I don't like it I am very envious
though when I went to Kmart I'd to wear
a red vest the blue best buy shirts look
way cooler yeah way cooler like you
could go out to the club you don't I'm
saying you turn that thing around turn
inside out pop the collar you got some
white pants on you can hit the club easy
you can't hit the club in a red Kmart
vest a which by the way and don't tell
anybody who works at Kmart but I own
like six of them because I kept
forgetting mine and I'd be like God can
I borrow on and feel like uh blares and
I just take it home by accident and I
have like six Kmart I've always wanted
for Halloween to me and my squad of
which I have to hire people hang out
with me what I'll go is kidding Kmart
employees
when does it Kmart they're turning into
a big K that summer is pretty good big
case got groceries pretty dumb
odd cat peach me out
it's always very humbling when you think
you do you think you do a good you do a
sweet mariokart move and you run
straight into a just brings you down a
couple pegs
damn dude hey mr. touchy don't spam
anybody I don't know something don't
make that gift
don't make us closet you ban a bunch of
people gave yourselves cat peach is just
on the prowl me out it's somebody in the
chat please just to make me happy just
use hash tag me out please just once I
just need to see it I need to see it in
print I'm sorry it just has to happen I
thank you guys Oh
[Music]
nice Jason I'm out of the creep around
the banhammer he was on jackass he'd be
van Laar Guerra
if he was on the Flintstones he'd be Bam
Bam Bam Bam no if he was he's the
wrestler
really hoping for
please it fix the tile on this road this
is terrible the infrastructure in the
zelda world is not good i would raise
taxes if i were then yeah sometimes like
no one wants to raise taxes but then you
know what keep the roads fall apart
never one's car starts dying and and
people resent the the government so
raise those taxes at least at least the
bridges and roads you know will the
upkeep will be good and also the schools
education is important for the citizens
of hyrule you know they got to learn how
to sword fight in magic spells install
God and stuff
oh good one waffle tarts benedict
cumberbatch that's yeah you win you win
waffle third use of gene this is madness
oh serious is this crazy madness yes
vaultboy fall out for height somebody
put a screen cap of me in fallout
shelter
it wasn't actually me but it looks
exactly like I think all the characters
are random that's right
have you always been a gamer just to
kill 21 because I teach all my friends
like you new to Conan yeah great I have
always been a gamer actually I remember
this is gonna date me but whatever I've
got great hair so that dates me already
I remember playing Robin Hood on the
Commodore 64 and you had to put a
cassette tape in a tape deck to load the
game and you would load it for 45
minutes it played through the entire
tape and then you can play one game and
you would get killed by the guy at the
flaming arrows every time after you
flaming arrow guy and then you have to
reload it and take another hour in it
hashtag the struggle is real my my
goodness my goodness let's play I think
we got one more race in us one more race
this is for all the marbles this game is
fantastic totally this game is super
good
paster monster truck bloopers it's my
favorite monster truck blooper I've been
to a lot of monster truck rallies my
favorite monster truck bloopers
obviously one where nobody gets visits
sucks when that happens I don't know I
kind of like it when I don't really know
it my favorite monster - are you talking
kind of blooper specific blooper things
you got to be more specific Squasher
what is the best blue light special your
store ever had we didn't have any blue
light specials actually at the Kmart uh
we didn't have any of those although I
did I mean I have a lot of good stories
about Kmart we'll save it for tomorrow's
truth a lot of good Kmart stories all
right ready last race dude this is it
okay it's the last one I'm sticking with
cat peach and I'm sticking with the wild
wiggler the wood wheels and the paper
thing this is a winning strategy what do
I drink I drink seltzer I drink a lot of
seltzer and a lot of coffee and then
also the blood of those who have wronged
me so those are my three favorite drinks
Seltzer
coffee
what those who rocked me
Volpe what am I most excited for and
fallout 4 I mean I don't know I love the
mud the whole being able to build stuff
is great I'm excited to see the world
before it got destroyed is really fun
I'm excited for a lot of things I love
fallout 3 it's fun all right here we go
we're gonna play let's play
I like the electric dome can we please
play there you're like nope no we can't
come on gonna touch me for the tingles
don't repeat that yeah let's go that'll
be a highlight for sure I love it
Arita you're right there's gonna be
amazing t-shirts seeing them the doors
open I'm getting awesome looks executive
producer who can't believe he's paying
me to play this game I can't either
thank you by the way thank you thank you
I think maybe tomorrow we'll shut the
door you would think in a shirt that
says edgy as heck you couldn't be
embarrassed but you'd be wrong you can
and I just got embarrassed am i blushing
I might be blushing oh look at this dude
looking it goes rainbow behind you this
is great this is amazing by the way
oh this is a fun level I don't know
what's happening with the pink area dude
this level is amazing people at San
Diego before we go this gonna be our
last race today but we're coming back
tomorrow noon pacific time to one we're
gonna have another special guest
tomorrow so make sure to stop by oh
goodness oh goodness
we can use some recommendations on where
to go down here in San Diego we'll be
here all week we are doing shows
Wednesday through Saturday at the
Spreckels theater and come on standby
tickets you can always combine and
you can get in on standby and do a show
I believe we're doing standby cam it
must be nice being an attorney that
knows things that are doing there we go
more information look at calm slash
tickets oh my goodness oh my goodness oh
I got that weird droplet I feel like
this is a track designed by Porter
Robinson you that is techno guy pretty
sweet love Porter Robinson
[Music]
oh my goodness
that motion controller Beth isn't using
a motion controller she just does that
it's just screw way
hashtag Beth's way that's she did it her
way which doesn't really do anything
extra yeah Porter Robinson Spitfire
thing about getting to Calvin Harris
only because he's dating Taylor Swift I
love Taylor Swift so I figured that
might bring me closer to Taylor Swift to
Tay Tay's Swift but I call her nobody
else calls her Taytay Swift oh that's my
name for it listen is some blank space
this morning such a good song shake it
off oh yeah exactly I love it favorite
in Tendo character is seafood I used to
do when I don't know what it's called I
would I used to hurt myself I used to go
what is why Luigi say yeah whatever I
used to say that all the time
I don't know Beth has no she has a Wii U
controller but it's it's it's one of
these it's this kind of controller but
it does say Wii U on it not their party
love Taylor Swift guys I think that's
gonna do it for today scream from the
hashtag Conan con danger 10 we're
calling it the danger day pretty great
we're gonna get a sign for it thank you
for joining us
big thanks to wil Myers from the Padres
follow him on twitter at wil Myers WL
and ye AR s you can also follow me on
instagram @ will underscore Myers follow
the Padres at Padres San Diego Padres
mlb.com I swear to you that's where you
are el and we will be streaming hashtag
stream Coco from this very spot the
Spreckels theater all week long so from
noon to one a Pacific time on twitch.tv
slash Team Coco and youtube.com slash
Team Coco so we'll see you guys tomorrow
another special guest another
another really fun game from breath
Morosky creeper adjacent amount of the
corner play to see you guys tomorrow
bye
you